もう別にそれは真実であって
その社会でもう一人の頭の悪い人が出てきて
とんでもないんだと 人は病気になるのはこの人悪いものを食べたんだからとかね
と言っちゃったら あんた何言ってるんだよ
嘘を言うなって それ悪いものを食べたものに霊が付いてたんだから
その人は病気になったんですよ
だからそれを体から出せば
この悪霊と一緒に出しちゃえばもう元気ですよって言っちゃうんだよ
どうしようもないんです
そこで現代社会では病気になるのは
まあ微生物のせいか あるいは体の臓器を機能しない
衰えて色々なるかっていう種類なんですね
であるいはもう一つあって
いろいろ科学的な何かね
流行ったりするとかね
まあありますけど 今も病気の原因というのは簡単単純に考えているんですね
だから悪霊の代わりに
まあウイルスやらいろんなバクテリアやらまあ入ってるだけで
悪霊もよく生き物でしょうね
遠い昔でも 霊だから でもウイルスも生き物でしょうに
考えてみると だから今も今知ってるのは真実で
昔っていうのは嘘だと言えないんです
当時のもうコンベンションはそうであったし
当時の決まりはそうであった
今の決まりは今でそうで
今はそうなっているし
そこで今我々は病気になったらそれなりの検査してもらって
ちゃんとした治療をしてもらうと
それで人々は病気を治したり
治らなかったり 死んだり
そういうミスなんですね
全然変わってないんです
こういうことでがんになるんだ
こういうことでがんになる
一生懸命もう考えたりするんだけど
がんになった人の中でがんが治る人がいて
もう治らなくて死ぬ人がいるんです
昔と今も同じことなんですね
ですから まあそんなに真剣に考えなくてもいいって
いわゆる真剣にならなくていいんですね
その理解はすごく大事なんで
アビダンマ始まる前に
この世俗態に対して すべては世俗態であると
これはまあ 13部のお坊さんたちがこういう黄色い系統の衣着ていると
日本のお坊さんたちは黒いものを着ていると
どっちでも勝手に着なさいということ
それをもってああだこうだというのはバカバカらしくても話ない
そういう話なんです 世の中でいろんな民族争いあるでしょう
自分の国でもあるでしょうに
例えばね まあこのボスニアとかね
そういうところで すごい残酷な状態があったりして
そういう人々は まあ仏教の立場から何やってるんですか
別にどうでもいいことで
ある民族は他の国であって
ある民族は他の民族と一緒にいて
どうでもいいことで それで
日本で生まれたんだから日本人というだけのことで
だからああだこうだと考えて困ったり
喧嘩したり もう人を殺したりとかね
そういうのは何も意味はないんです
それから学問的な知識にせとっても
ある人は地理学を勉強していて
ある人は考古学を勉強していると
別にどうったことないんです
だから何です？と聞きたいところなんです
世の中で一番役に立つ仕事は何ですか？と
そんなことあるわけないんです
ある人はもう電車を運転して
ある人は車をタクシーとかいろんなものを運転している
ある人は飛行機を操縦しているし
ある人はもう会社でいろいろこすこすとやっているし
もう ある人は学校でいろいろむちゃくちゃ教えているしね
どっちでも同じことで
結局はもうつまらないことをやっているだけのことなんです
じゃあ学校の教えることはすごい仕事ですと言ったっても
大したこと教えてないの
ちょっとした狭いことをやっているだけなんで
その人の人生というのはそれで決まるわけじゃないんだから
算数を教える人は算数ばっかり教えて
そればっかり大事であるならば
もうそれだけ教えてればいいんだけども
それ算数ばっかり勉強してたらもう全然役に立たない人間になってしまっちゃいますから
ですから まあどんな仕事一番役に立つかとかね
自分の仕事つまらないんだとかね
そういうのはもう違いないんだから
もうことでもっと面白い仕事ないんですか？とか
もっと大事な仕事ないんですか？とかね
何言ってるんですかと
私は自分のこともそう思っている
私はもうたまたま出家したんだから
もうこういうことをやっているんであって
別に皆様と何の差もないんだと
私はこういうことを知ってるんだから教えるんだって
別に偉いわけでも何でもないんです
面白くも面白くなくない
面白くないでどっちでもないんです
例えば人々から羨ましいわとか
何言ってるんですかと聞きたいんですね
何が羨ましいんです もし私のことを羨ましいんだったら
私はあなたのことも羨ましいんですと
僕は本気でそう思っている
たまにこの あんた方はいろいろね
結婚もしてないし いろいろそういう悩みこともないしね
子供もないんだから まあ楽で大変羨ましい生活だなとかね
というと 私もそういう人々のことを羨ましがっちゃうんですね
自分でわがまま勝手に生きていられない
子供のことで悩まなくちゃいけない
どうやってもいくら悪い子供であろうと捨てるわけにもいきません
一生懸命忍耐して もう子育てを育てようとしている
あの努力は自分にはないんだから
羨ましいなと すごい修行をしてるんだと思ったりはしているんです
僕だったら 例えば子供たちの面倒を見ていて
なかなか言うことを聞いてないから
あんた方は帰りなさいと言っちゃえばそれで終わるでしょうに
でも両親にはそんなことできないでしょ
いくらもうとんでもない悪い子供であろうとも
一生懸命面倒見なくちゃいけない
ですから その目で見れば
そちら側も大変羨ましいです
そこで普通の人から見れば
まあ子育てやら仕事やら
もう食べることだけでもう人生終わって死んでしまっちゃうし
まあ超一流の心理やらそういうことを聞く暇もない
僕にとってはそういうことは子供の時からずっとやっていたんだから
普通の人から見ればそれを羨ましいと思うかもしれませんし
ですから 世の中でそんなことは何もなく
全部決まりですと 全部決まりです
全ては嘘とは言わない
決まりだから真実であると
でも徹底した論理的な何か根拠あるわけじゃない
そこでこの僕はこの延々とし喋っているわけじゃないんで
この一応ここ大変大事なポイントなんです
アビダンマの始まるところで
そこでこの世俗体の特色
生きているしかないです
特色でたった一つ その世俗体と世俗体と言うんだけど
すぐ変えるんですね 変えてしまうんです
変化してしまうんです
世俗体は で 科学は一番いい例なんですね
科学にはまあそんなに長い歴史はないんだけど
やっぱりものすごい変化の歴史ですね
ある時期で これこそといった法則はもうちょっと時間経つと違うんだと
すぐ変化してしまうんですね
それは世俗体の特色なんです
これこそ真実だ 本物だともう捕まってもちょっと時間経つと
変化しています で 皆様
我々の経験の中から見ても
例えば 10年前で これが人間の正しい生き方だとかね
こういうふうに生きるのが理想的な生き方だとか
こうしなくちゃいけない
ああしなくちゃいけないということは
今は全く違うでしょうに
例えばバブルの以前とバブル後の我々の生き方を見ても
ものすごく変わっているんだから
消費税導入した時はみんな腹が立って
私も腹が立ったんだけど
で いろいろ反対 いろんなことがあったりして
年経つと当たり前のことになってしまっちゃうんです
全然もう気にしなくなっちゃう
でも聞こうともしないで
税込みでこの値段ですよと
何か物を買うともう向こう側から言っても全然聞いてない
もういくらですか？と
最後にはいくらですかと
初めは私もやっぱりこれぐらい税金で取られるなとかね
これは良くないなとか思ったりしたんです
今はそんなこと関係なく
もういくら払えばいいかと
それ55%になるとまた腹が立っちゃいますけど
また年 三年経つと もう何のことなくなってしまっちゃうんです
そこで そういう風にこの世の中の決まりっていうのはもうすぐ変わる
そういうのは分かりやすい変わり方です
例えばこの病気にこの薬だよということをそれ変わってしまっちゃうんですね
後からそんなそれじゃなくてこれでいいやと
例えば今 最近だったら
やっぱりいろいろ薬をもうがぶがぶ飲むんじゃなくて
やっぱりできるだけ自然のままで
自然の法則の中で自然と一緒になって生きていた方がより健康的で病気早く治りますよという考え方もありますし
それを言ってる人々はこれこそ真実やともう言いたがってますけど
僕は別にまあ勝手にしろという感じでいる
なんか鈴木さんと話やったんだけど
どこかでこのどこでしたっけ？自然食やってるところで瞑想会の話やったんですね
で あのバイオ 何何？マイクロバイオティック
マイクロバイオティックのことで
もう癌も治ってああだこうだということで
そういうアメリカにいる日本人の
それも開発さみたいな
もう大物なんですけどね
その人のセミナーで そこでちょっと 1時間ぐらい瞑想はどうですかと僕らに話があったんだけど
鈴木さんはやっぱりすごい断りたかったんだけど
僕はまあ時間があればやったりだとかいう風に言ったんですけど
やっぱり鈴木さんの気持ちはわかるんです
まあ一応 まあちょっと 1時間だけね
まあくだらないことをやっても
瞑想は遊ぶもんじゃないという気持ちなんですけど
で 私もまあ所詮遊んでいるんだからろくな目にならないんだからまあいいじゃない
そこで一応 あんまりにもこの食べ物のこと
食べ物のことばっかし向こうは言ってるんですね
で なんかこれこそ真実だと
マイクロバイオティックこそ人間の
もうそれこそ食べ物だと
これ聞いていられない
こっちもやっぱりもうどんどんもうこれこそというところはもう聞いていられないところですね
全部喋って終わったら
まあちょっと私のまあ余計な冗談の話なんですけど
あんた方えらい贅沢ですねと言ったんです
どういうことかと 世の中人は食べ物がなくてね
何が食べ物あればいいなと困っている時代で
あんた方は何考えてるんですかと
これとんでもない罪と思いますよと
私はね 犯罪罪だと思いますよ
と言ったら もう向こうは当然ながらもうものすごいもうきつい反応来るのはこれは計算済みですけどね
で そこでやっぱりまあ僕らから見ればね
やっぱり人々を助けてあげることはもっといいなとは思ってますよと言ったところで
答えは いいえ これで世界平和は成り立ちますと
人々は肉 魚を食べてるんだから
もうすごい悪い悪人になってるんだと
それでずっとマイクロバイオティック的な食べ物を食べて
それすごい高いでしょうね
1,000円で食べるものは
2300円ぐらい 2500円ぐらいかかるマイクロバイオティックになっちゃうと
もっとかかるかもしれません
食べるとものすごい心清らかになって
世界をの平和的な国を作るという
そういう尊い教えですと言ったって
僕にはくだらない話にしか聞こえないんですね
で なぜかというと まあそれもそれなりの理屈なんです
別に僕は否定するわけじゃないんです
人々はもう残酷に肉やら魚やら食べると
もう相手の命は全く気にしない
もう恐ろしい人間になるのは確かなんですね
生命のことをどうでもいいんで
どんな肉食えばいいんですか？とかね
どういう風に食えばいいんですかって
それは分かります そこで体に悪い食べ物を食べると体が壊れる
それも分かります だからといって
肉 魚食べない人々は戦争しないんですかね
インド見るとほとんど菜食主義の数が多いんだから
ちょっとしたことでも殺し合いやってるでしょ
ちょっと違うカーストの人が学校に入っちゃったら
みんな立ち上がってもう追い出そうとするし
あれは何ですかね そうすると
インド人も結局このマイティバイとかそういう概念なくたって
もうすごく自然に従って
化学的ないろんな調味料とか何も使わないで
ものすごい素晴らしい食べ物を食べて
それをもう医学的に素晴らしいものを食べて生きているのに
あんなもんなんです ちょっとしたことでものすごい大騒ぎして暴動を起こしたりして
散々殺したり殺し合いやったりをする
スリランカでも世界一流の恐ろしいこのテロだグループになっているタミル人も
ほとんどはヒンドゥー教で菜食主義なんです
肉魚食べてる仏教の人々は一人も殺そうとしていないのに
その人々は定期で一般の人々を殺しているしですから
そういう立場で見ると
あの宣誓しちゃってるけど
もうなんかちょっとどうかなと思うんですね
あれはもう僕から僕の目で見ると
あんまりにも贅沢して贅沢しすぎて出てくる反応だけであって
別にそれこそということはない
でもマイティバイというか
もうもう何年前から結構流行ってる概念ですけど
ある時期でそういうのは流行っていて
ちょっと前はやっぱりちゃんとした動物性のタンパク質取らなくちゃいけないという考え方もありましたし
それもそれで正しいし
マイティバイの教えもそれでそれで正しいし
どっちでももう別に だからどっちが徹底的な真実かと問われますかね
だから食は この世俗体はどんどんどんどん変わっていくということなんですね
どこまで変わるかわからないんです
とにかく変わっていくんです
今は正しいというものが
明日になると正しくなくなっちゃうし
それはよく理解してください
これは大変な教えなんです
それは決して人の教えは貶すことではない
僕は大変失礼なことを今マイティバイのそれと言ったんだけど
それは決してその教えは間違っているということではないんです
その枠の中で その考え方の中で
それは正しいんです あるそれなりの原因があるんだから
証拠があるんだから そういう考え方が出来上がったんだよ
もっと前にヨーロッパ的な人々がいろいろ研究したところで
やっぱりいろんなタンパク質を取らなくちゃいけないんだ
だから動物性のタンパク質が一番いいタンパク質だと
だから肉魚食べなさいという風な概念もあった
それはそれなりの当時の研究結果としては
それはそれで正しい教えでもありましたし
それで体には肉魚悪いんだから
みんな菜食主義にしなさいっていうのも
それもまたもう残念ながら正しいんですね
なぜならば やっぱり動物性のもののいろいろ体に合わないものはいっぱい入っていて
植物にはそういうものはないんですね
ですから 菜食主義の方がより健康的だと言ってるんですね
それも考えると それも合ってるんです
だからとことん肉魚食べなさいということも真実であって
いえ 違います マクロバイオティック的なものを食べなさいというのも真実であって
五穀の菜食するのもそれでそれまた真実で
全部世俗諦なんですね
それで私はもうちょっとケチをつけたいんだけど
じゃあ何て言います 植物だけを食べてるんだ
それで体が健康的になるんだと言ったら
それまた違いますね トリカブトとか食べてみてください
あれ植物でしょう もう片っ端から森の中で見つかるキノコとかね
格好いい すごい綺麗な赤いとかね
黄色いの それから青い点々とかね
すごい綺麗なキノコあるんです
食べてください もう植物です
あれは だから何言ってるんですか？と
結局植物の中にも体に毒があるんです
それはまあ 世俗諦 という世俗諦です
それで 僕はできるだけわかりやすくしようということで
こういう風に話しましたけど
それから少々アビダンマ的な解釈に入ります
で このテキストを私は持ち上げて皆様に見せたら
皆様に何を見るんですかというと
今私はこのテキストを持ち上げています
で 皆さんに見せています
皆様は同じものを見ています
それには相違はない そこで私は各人に聞く
あんた見たもの何ですか？と
じゃあ想像してください
同じ答えが返ってきますか
同じ答えが返ってこないんです
ある人はこれはアビダンマの本ですと
ある人はアビダンマのテキストです
ある人は本ですと ある人はテキストですと
と言うんですね それじゃあ見たのは何ですかね
それだったら アビダンマの本ですか？アビダンマのテキストですか？ただのテキストですか？ただの本ですか？どっちですか？みんな同じものを見たんだから
同じ答えが出てくるでしょうに
だからこれを大人に教えるのは難しいんです
これ子供だったらすごく簡単に教えられるんです
子供だったら いちいちそういう風に実証的にやられるんです
で 子供は遊びながらも結構うまくこれ吸収するんです
だからこういう教えは子供の時に教えておけば立派な人間になるのは当たり前なんです
全然喧嘩しないし ああだこうだとかね
お互いにこの あの人だったら羨ましいとかね
私だったら惨めでダメだとか
そんな感じ何にもなく堂々と現前できてるんです
それだったら 勉強できる子もできない子も堂々と現前できてるんです
あんたに勉強できるんだから何だよと
自分に勉強できないんだから他のことできるぞという感じで
だから僕は小さい頃は自分では勉強できた方なんですけど
でも僕は勉強できない人を見ると羨ましかったね
やっぱり自分には勉強できる中で
この人々にはもう体格が強くて
スポーツはできるは あれはできる
これはできるは これ大したもんだと
勉強もできないバカな連中だと全然一度も思ったことはないんです
そういうふうなこの もうすぐこの世俗諦
世俗諦さえ理解すれば
もうそれでもう人格をもう成仏しちゃいます
ですから この皆様とはなかなかそういう切実な遊びできませんだけど
だからちょっとこの この迫力というか
もうこれちょっと失うんですね
もうあんまりもう 大学の授業でも
まあどうせ学生たちだからもう結構からかっちゃいますけど
僕は 当時は 問題なかったんだけど
一応考えてみてください
この本 もうダメですけど
この場合は で じゃあ私はこれを見せます
これ何ですかと自分では答えてください
どれぐらい答えが来るんですかと
いろんな答えが来るんですね
でもみんな見たものは同じものなんでしょうに
それは世俗諦の世界なんです
まあまあ 私はまあこういうものを見せたんだけど
まあそれはカバンだという人がいるかもしれませんし
まあいろんなことを言うでしょうね
カバンと言ったと 例えばこのテープレコーダーで聞く方々は
私はカバン見せたんだけど
どんなものを想像するんですかね
全く違うカバンを想像するでしょうに
皆様はこれはカバンだと思うかもしれません
それはスマナサーラさんの道具だと思う人もいるかもしれませんし
それはお坊さんたちのものだと思うかもしれません
それはススキさんとスマナサーラさんとホソノさん持っているものだと思う人もいるし
で いろいろでしょうね
それでテープレコーダーで聞く人々もまた違うイメージでしょうね
じゃあそれに据えて喧嘩するんですかね
我々は するべきですかね
だから 見たものについても
我々の理解は決して真実ではないんです
見ても見えるのは世俗態
聞いても聞こえるのは世俗態なんです
で あの そういうことで大変
あの この世俗態とこの世俗態っていうのは
それには当てにならないということと
変化するということを理解してください
別に嘘ということでもない
私が持っているカバンを見せて
皆さん見せて 皆様方から何を見たんですか？と聞いたら
もう 10人聞いたら 10種類の答えが出てくるんだけど
その 10種類も嘘を言ってるわけじゃない
誰でもカバンを見て これはラジオですよって言わないんだから
自分知ってる真実を語ってるんです
だからといって なんで同じものを見て 10人が 10種類の答えが出てくるかというと
それは唯一の真実でもないということにもなるんです
うん で 次のは これ私はこれを見せます
これを見せたら いくらか同じ答えが来るかもしれませんね
これは時計ですと  それでも違う言葉が出てくるかもしれませんし
まあ時計と言った途端
時計見ないで思う人々はいろんな時計を思いますけどね
それでこの時計というのは
やっぱり一応決めましょう
これに時計という言葉を
そうでないと困りますから
これは時計ですと じゃあ皆様はこれを見ますと
そこで あ みんな同じ意見に立ったでしょうに
今私の手にあるのは時計ですということ
じゃあそれだったら真実ですかと
それちょっとまたわからない
例えば 私はこの時計のこの
この なんていうか チェーンをつける
これ何て言いますかね
上のこのフックみたいなものあるんですね
これ簡単に外せるんです
こうやって それで一部外れる
外してみる あるいはこの回す
このノブですか それを取る
蓋を開ける バラバラにする
この時計を バラバラにしたところでどうなるんですかね
まず最初は確実に時計はありました
それから私は  これは今はちょっとバラバラにすることはできませんだけど
道具がないんで まあですからやめますけど
で 時計があって それで蓋を
開けて別においたら蓋に皆様方は時計の蓋と言うんですか？この蓋と言うんです
で ノブを外しちゃったら
それは時計のノブだと
ダイヤルにはこれダイヤです
ダイヤルでした 針には時計の針でした
そういう風になってて
最後に我々見つかるのは針やらダイヤルやらノブやら色んなものなんですね
歯車やら電池やら じゃあ時はどこ行ったんですかね
バラバラにするならばもうありますよ
できるものは じゃあこれは何ですかというと
これはボールペンと言うんですね
これは じゃあこれは何ですかと
この蓋になっちゃうんですね
じゃあそうするとこれまたバラして
これは何ですかという
これ何と言いますか で
これは何ですか で これどこまででもバラせるんですね
まあ一応仮にこれにボディと言いましょう
日本語で何と言います？わかりませんけども
これボールペンのボディで
これはボールペンの芯で
で これは蓋で これはもう先に付ける
もうこれもしかすると金属かどっちかわかりませんけど
これはプラスチックかな
で こういうものがあって
で それからこの中を見るとね
まあインクが入って見せるものだから
特別なインク入ってるもん
で まあ一応金色のインクがあって
それはインクはインクで
この先っぽいのものは
あの 書くためのある金属的な部分なんですね
それ一つ一つに別な名前がありまして
別な仕事があるんですね
それ一つもボールペンではないんです
じゃあボールペンはどこ行ったんですかね
これこの蓋を見て あ これはボールペンだという人はいません
このボールペンを入れるこの芯を入れるこのプラスチックのこのこの
バレル これを見て 誰もこのボールペンのボディを見てボールペンだと言わないんです
そこでこういう風に繋げたところで
ある法則によって合わせるんですね
これは いわゆるこのかける部分は外へ出す
これこう中に入れないんです
こうやってある法則によって合わせるんですね
こうやって で 合わせたところで
それで蓋も閉めて これでボールペン
今ボールペンが存在する
もうちょっと前はボールペンはなかったんですね
だからボールペンがあるということは別に嘘ではないんだから真実です
でもちょっとバラしちゃったらどうなったんですかというと
ボールペンは消えちゃって
違う真実が生まれたんです
蓋というものは存在するようになっちゃった
芯というものは存在するようになりました
インクというものは存在するようになりました
金属部分というものは存在するようになりました
そこで最初の真実はすぐ変化しました
じゃあこれで終わりですか？終わりじゃない
これは限りなく変化していくんです
このボールペンは燃えますから
燃えちゃったらまた変化するんですね
そこでボールペンはなくて
煙やら灰やら有機ガスやら
生まれるんですね そういうものに変化させてしまう
どっちが正しいんですか？だから世俗
世俗 世俗帯っていうのは
そういう風に ある条件の中で
あ そう そうでしょうと思うだけ
条件変えれば違うものになってしまっちゃうんです
いろいろ例で考えてください
で 建物というでしょ 本当に建物あると思ってしまいますけど
やっぱり屋根を別にしたりとかね
もう梁を別にしたりとか
壁の板とか全部外したりとかしてみると
もう板がありまして 瓦がありまして
梁がありましたり 木材いろいろありましたりとかね
ものすごいこのがらくたばっかしがありまして
建物がなくなっちゃうんですね
普通 建物というとすごい高価なもので
ものすごいお金もかかるし
使う時でもお金すごいかかっちゃうし
大変高価なの 例えば いくらこの床につけてるこういうタイルとかね
すごい高いもんなんですね
でも外してみてください
ただのゴミ それも あの
燃えないゴミだから 処分するのは大変困ると
1円もない たくさんなったらそれであの
お金払って処分してもらわなくちゃいけない
こちらがお金払わなくちゃいけないんですね
そこをちょっとわかってほしいんです
それは接触体 ちょっと変わったらとんでもない結果になってしまっちゃうんです
違うものになるんです
車を見てください 車っていうのは
いろんなこの何の役にも立たないくだらない部品がある法則によってまとめたら
あ 車だ これは 1000万円の値打ちのある高い車だとかね
1つずつバラしてみてください
で 自然破壊するただのゴミになってしまっちゃうんです
それで車という 言うんだけど
車たるものはない ボールペンと言うんだけど
ボールペンたるものはない
本と言うんだけど 本たるものはない
ですから ずいぶん変化していく
真実は接触体と言います
じゃあ最後の 1 分で あの正義体
いわゆるパラマットサッチャということを説明します
パラマットサッチャ 日本語で正義体と言うんですね
まあ正義体といえば いわゆる意味としては優れている意味等で
まあもういい加減な意味の真実ではなくて
やっぱり優れてる意味のという意味なんですね
これはもうちゃんとこの直訳なんで
正義と パラマは優れているという
アッタは意味 義ですね
ですから こういう人間のいい加減な解釈ではなくて
もうとことん我々の世界をとことん極めて極めてみていくと
何が見つかるかと そんな勝手に変化するというふうに言えない
というか ちょっと言葉の過ちになっちゃいますけど
いわゆる本当に？じゃあだから何ですかと
この何でも変化しちゃうでしょ
何でもその時だけの真実ではどうでもいいことでしょうに
じゃあ一体全体この存在というものは何ですかと
最終的な意味として 理解として見る
見ると見つかるものは生起体というんです
それ私の喋り方だけ難しいんだけど
別に内容難しくないんです
今日は色即体だけ理解して
これすごい新しい哲学として世の中その意味で見てください
面白いんです 人々はいろんなことを喋るでしょうに
もう人の悪口言うし もう人のいいところも言うし
噂も言うし 一生懸命もう真剣本気になって
やっぱり全ては色即体だという気持ちで聞いてみて生きてみてください
ものすごいなんか心が自由になって
混乱ない 悩み苦しみない
心がすぐそこで生まれるはずなんです
で 皆様はどんな食べ物を食べた方がいい
北を見て食べた方がいいです
南も方向を見て食べた方がいい
いろんなものを世の中作るでしょうに
それで考えたり勉強したり
あっち走ったりこっち走ったり
もうえらい苦しみを感じてるんです
別にそういうものは嘘でもなくて
まあそれなりのわけで
そういうことであって
これはこれでこういうことであってとかね
見ていくと そこでなんとなくすごくこの執着しない
何ものにもとらわれない生き方が
人間がそこで出てきちゃうんです
たったそれだけで じゃあアビダンマの素晴らしさはわかりました
ただそれだけで この目に見える真実ですから
それだけで実践していると
すぐそこで人はもう普通の人間よりも超えてるすごい人間になってしまっちゃうんです
例えば ある人が私のところに来て
何々さんがとんでもない人ですよと
もう信頼できませんよとか
裏切り者ですよと 別に私は困る必要はないし
あんた嘘つきと言う必要もないし
あるいはあの人 私はすごく信頼できる人だよと言って
その人と喧嘩する必要もないし
例えば人が来てAさんのことを僕に言うと A
さんは裏切り者だ 信頼できないんだとか
ああだこうだとかね 私を騙しましたとかね
普通我々はどうしますか？あんたも気をつけなさいと
Aさんはちょっともう信頼できない
ああそうですか じゃあ私もあの人のこと今日から気をつけますとかなっちゃうでしょう
で 色即体の立場で見ると
別にその人は嘘を言ってるわけでもないし
真実知ってるわけでもないし
その いえ 違います 私はあなた何言おうともAさんを信じますよと
その人と喧嘩する必要でもないし
何のことないでしょう
その代わりに じゃああなたはなぜAさんが裏切り者と思いますか？と
私はこういう約束したんだけど
彼は約束破ったと あ そうですか
それはそれだけなんです
それは事実ですから だからAさんが裏切り者になりますかね
なれない なぜならば  Aさんに聞いてみれば
違うストーリーが出てくる可能性はいくらでもあるし
だからそのストーリーも正しいわけでもないし
このストーリー正しいわけでもないし
自分の よく見るとすごい自由な
でも物事よく見える なるほど
この人はこういう約束はきちんと実行してくれると信じ込んでいたんだ
でも実行してくれなかった
だから裏切り者だと解釈しているんだと
それはその人の解釈 A
さんから聞けば まあどうせその人にはそんなことをしてあげる義理がないんだと
という状態でもうやるつもりは
やってあげるつもりは初めからなかったんだと
そうすると別に裏切ったわけじゃないんです
本人が やってあげるという気持ちなかったんだから
なるほど その人から見れば
このBさんは別に何かしてあげるぐらい義理のない人であって
迷惑ですと と解釈しているんだと
そういう風になっちゃうでしょうね
それで物事を見えている
でも自分が誰の肩も取らない立派な人間になってくる
その上 もしこのBさんが私はだからどうすればいいんですかと
もしちょっと相談に乗ってくる
相談してあげることもできる
あなたはこういうふうにすればいいんじゃないかと
ですから この色即体だけでも理解すれば
そこにお釈迦様おっしゃってる
この生き方というか 本当の生き方
生きるべき道っていうのはすぐそこに現れてくるんです
まあそれだけ理解すればアビダンマいらなくなっちゃいますけど
それで生起体っていうのは
まあそういう風に物事を変化するんだけど
そういう現象ではなく
色即体はすべて現象論です
[背景音楽]現象ではなく
この何と言いますか 現象の反対が何ですかね
反対の言葉ありますか？英語だったらノーミナン
フェノーメノンノーメナントですけどでしょうね
ノーメナンというのは一応決まってる言葉ですけど
この日本語で適当な言葉ないな
まあ一応 私もあまり関心はないし
頭の中で世俗体では全部現象で見てしまっちゃう
で まあこういうこと 実際に何があってこの現象生まれたか生まれたんですかと
と見ることは生起体なんです
なんですが このこれから生起体の勉強に入りますけど
それ二 三年かかる可能性ありますけど
この生起体の勉強には
まあそれはそれで とりあえずもう一応大雑把にごく普通に一般的にわかりやすく
私は今度はアビダルマのこのコースをやろうと思ってるんです
あんまりこの専門的なところにいかないで
できるだけアビダルマのアビダルマらしさをカットして
もっと人間の世界に戻って喋りたがって喋りますと思ってるんです
で あの生起体の説明は長い時間かかりますが
その時でも我々がスーッと追ってくる問題はこの世俗体なんです
世俗体でしか生起体は理解できないんです
これが生起体と言ったっても
それは世俗体になっちゃうんです
それがあるんです それは我々がこのいくらが進んだところで
もう簡単なところで解決します
いくらアビダルマが進んだら
まあちょっとした分析で
まあこういうことですよ
そういうもうちょっと一言でも解決してしまいます
例えばこの生起体という言葉自体も結局世俗体
なくしちゃいますから
じゃあこの じゃあアビダルマって何ですかというと
あの 特別に何か特別な科学的な説明というよりは
このアビダルマ 仏教はね
世の中こう見ているんですね
世の中 地球は丸いであろうが
四角いであろうが それはもうそれで結構ですと
問題はここに私がいて
私がいてっていうのは
またもう大雑把な言葉で何か認識するんですね
目で何か認識する 耳で何か認識する
体で何か感じる 鼻で何か嗅ぐ
舌で味を味わう そこで脳細胞でいろんなことを考える
そこからこの問題生まれてるでしょうに
[笑い]この地球って
この大地は地球かあるいは平らかという問題は出てきたのはこの目で見ていたんだからでしょ
人間には全くそういう目がなかったならば
そんなものは生まれてこないでしょうに
どういうことでしょう
それだったら だからこのバカみたいく地球は平らかとかね
あるいは球の状態かとか
それじゃなくて 目って物事を見る
そこら辺勉強してみると
いわゆる我々が何を認識するか
そこは生起態なんです
我々実際に何を認識するかっていうこと
例えばこの私は最初このテキスト見せたところで
あるいは私のカバン見せたところで
皆様方は認識したものは一つであることは一応言えるんですね
でもこれは何ですかと聞くと
いろんな言葉が出てくる
昨日も勉強してた言葉なんですけど
すだぶくろなんとかって言って
このカバン見て ある方がこのすだぶくろの新しいものは綺麗ですと言ったんですね
僕 僕が答えたのはこの言葉に答えたんではなくて
これは新しいものじゃない
すごい古いものですと
ただ洗っただけですと
僕は知っておいて知って欲しかったのは
僕は全然洗わないで 汚いまんまで使ってる使ってる
まあいい加減な人間だよっていうことを言いたかったんだけど
そこら辺にはその方の知識が動かなかったし
すごく新しくて綺麗ですよと
新しい 僕はもう私は新しい袋を使っていると思ったんですね
私から見れば別に新しい袋じゃないと
これもう二年もっとかな
古いもので 洗ってなかったんですね
最近洗ったんです  それ関係ない
それすだぶくろ 新しい古い関係ない
いえ だからすだぶくろ
だからその人はこれ 新しくてかっこいいということに興味があって
だからこのすだぶくろは新しい
新しいもの それはすごくかっこいいと
で だからそれぞれの人の認識の世界違うんです
それで私はその瞬間で
その人の何言おうとしてる世界ではなくて
全く違う別世界にいるんですね
僕はこの最近洗ったよという
今まで全然洗わないで汚いもの使っていたということに
僕の暦があって で 今の場合は
私はカバンという言葉に重点を置く
そこでこの袋を皆様に見せたら
これ袋ですよ すだぶくろですよ
カバンですよとかね これはもう外国のもので
いろいろ意見は出てくるかもしれません
それで問題は とにかくこのすだぶくろを見る方々は何か一つのものを見る
そこでいろいろ違う認識が生まれるんだけど
この違う認識を救うために何が自分の体に入ったんですかと
いわゆる情報は何ですか
その情報は個人がいろんな解釈をする
それで世俗体が生まれる
これ世俗体が生まれるのは人々の認識次第なんですね
これをこの古いカバン見たんだから
昨日の方がそれはすごく新しいカバンですよと思っただけで
それはその解釈であって
一度も見たことがない人だったら
別に新しいものか古いものかと関係なくなっちゃうし
そういうのは全部世俗体
初めてその袋を見る人は別に袋だと
そこは真実というんじゃなくて
それは世俗体 そこで生起態っていうのは
何を見たかっていうことなんです
いわゆる見る場合は何か目に触れないと見られないんですね
だからこれをあげると
耳に 耳ではなくて目に何か触れる
この触れるものを勉強するのは生起態なんです
そうすると差が生まれません
目に触れるものはもう決まってるんです
じゃあ先生 体験によって認知するっていうのも違う
だから体験によって認知するものは全部世俗体だと
で このなかなか認識する場合は解釈いろいろ入る
この解釈する以前に最初にこの認識をの
の波を起こすでしょ その引き金は何ですかと
あの有名なストーリーがありまして
ある ある日このいっぱいお腹いっぱい餌を食べてウサギさんが寝ていたんですね
昼寝している そこでもうあまりにも食べ過ぎていろんなことを妄想しているんだと
そこでも あの もし あの
この 自分寝ているこの大地ですか
ズブンと翻っちゃったらどうするでしょうかね
やっぱり早く逃げなくちゃいけないんだとかね
こんなにもうグズグズと寝ている時じゃないんだ
さっさと飛んで逃げていかなくちゃいけないんだ
そうするとどうなるんでしょうかとかね
どうやって逃げればいいんですかと妄想しているんです
寝て そこでそこで枯れ葉がいっぱいあって
そこで木の 木から何か
あの 木の実が一つポーンと落ちたんですね
落ちたら すごい音してたんです
音して これもうびっくりして立ち上がって
やっぱり大地が  繰り返してくるんだと
でも走り出したんですね
もう後ろ見ないでも走り出す
そこで他のウサギさんが「あんたどこへ走るんだ？」「大地がもう転がってくるんだから早く逃げろ」と 「
あ そう じゃあ逃げろ」と
みんな逃げる 他の動物にも言う
みんな聞くと もうみんな一斉に逃げるんだ
それを逃げて逃げて 最終的にもうまた同じ
もうライオンが寝ているんですね
でもあまり大騒ぎ すべての動物が逃げるんだから
で ライオンが「あんた方なんで大騒ぎしているんですか」って言ったら
ライオンに喋れる動物が「やっぱり大地が転がってくるってことだから
我々は命を惜しんで逃げるんだと
だから 王様も逃げてください」と
言ったら その自分 「この人
あんた見たの？」「いいえ
私は見てないんだけど
この こいつから聞いたんだ
でお前見たの？」と いちいち探していくんですね
最終的には誰も見てないんです
で ウサギさんに聞くんです 「
お前見たんですか？」と
だから その犯人はその人だから
そこで「いいえ 私も見てないんだけど
やっぱりそういう音がしたんだから
逃げたんだと じゃあ見てみよう」と見たら
そこに あの 硬い木の実が枯れた葉っぱの上に落ちてあったんだと
そこは事実であって それは変化する
変化しないんです 起きた出来事は
でもそれに全ての認識はえらく変化しているんです
そこで動物たちの世界はデサブタエの世界で
ライオンが の道がショーグタイの道であります
それはジャータカ物語もありまして
イーソップ物語もありますからね
だから仏教のストーリーなんです
もともとは で うまいこと言ってるんです
あの  そうすると我々はつ見つかるんだそうです
一つはチッパ これ あの
これはつに分けます  [紙をめくる音]こういう四つの将義体
出てきます あの 一応これからこの仏教で使うほとんどの専門用語は出てきます
ですからパーリ語も覚える努力をした方が
あの もともとの意味で仏教は理解できるんです
アビダンマ勉強するということは
この仏教で使っているこの専門用語
全部使う 特にアビダンマッサンガっていうこのすると
この これの言葉全部覚えておけばもう問題ないんです
仏教を理解できるために
チット チットが まあ心ですね
で 心って何ですかと 次の勉強会で説明に入ります
一応私がいろんなものあるということを知るんだからでしょ
こうする問題は 目で物を見るんだからでしょ
耳でものを聞いてるんだからでしょ
もう全部哲学やら科学やらありとあらゆるものが体が痛いと感じるだからでしょう
病気だとかいろんなこと考えるのは
ですから それはこの認識する働き
心 いわゆる認識機能 心っていうのは認識機能
チェータシカというのは
この認識と一緒に生まれる感情
感情 もろもろの感情 でもそれはそれほどのいい意味じゃないんです
ちょっと説明します 例えば心が認識機能があって物は認識する
それで終わらないんですね
あ 古い部屋だ あ 綺麗な花だとかね
そうなっちゃうでしょ
何か見たら あ 美味しい食べ物だと
こっち食べ物があって
こっち花があるという世俗
世俗体で喋る場合は 結構見るものは同じなんですけど
科学的に言えば そこで
あ これは綺麗な あ これ美味しい食べ物だとだとか決めちゃっちゃうんですね
それなりに我々の心の感情が変化するでしょう
人を見る時でも 見られる人によって心の中で違う違う感情が生まれる
ですから それも自分で体験できるものなんですね
怒りやら苦しみやら悩みやら嫉妬やらね
もう明るさやら眠気やらつまらなさやら
いろんなものが生まれちゃうんです
心の中で それは自分で知っている
そういうありとあらゆるもろもろの感情
いいものであろうと悪いもので関係なく
仏教の知恵もここに入っているんです
悟ったぞという 本当に悟った時でも
それは一つの心に生まれる結果なんです
だから 例えばこの自分たちが見たくてしょうがない
たまらない 世界的なすごい有名な画家の絵を一つ見たんだ
見たところ すごいびっくりするでしょうね
あ これはあの本物の絵ですかと
すごい感動するでしょ
そういうふうに神経を見ると
ある心に変化が起こる
それを智慧と呼んで それも心性の一部なんです
ですから 善悪と関係なく心に生まれる一切のもろもろの感情は心性というんです
色というのは 3番目の色
物質的な世界 いわゆるこういうこと
自分がものを認識機能あるんですね
認識機能あるんだけど
この認識機能はある光の中で働いているんですね
[笑い]体という機械の中に認識機能が起こっているんだから
目という機械なければ見えませんでしょうに
見えるという認識は目がなければ生まれませんし
耳という機械がなければ聞くという認識機能は生まれませんし
舌がなければ甘いか辛いかわかりますか？わからない
体に感覚なければ世の中でいるかいないかわかりますかね
座っても立っても全然わかりませんだからそれだったら
ですからこの機械なんですね
機械の世界 そこで目があって
私は壁がある 部屋があると思っちゃうでしょうに
音が入ると あ 隣の部屋があると思ってしまっちゃうんです
そういう外の世界も 結局私にとっては機械の世界
いわゆる物質の世界 ですから色っていうのは物質の世界
そこで番目のニッバーナ
涅槃 何ですかというと
このつの世界を理解して
全部理解したところで
この何ものにもとらわれる意味がないという知恵の感情が生まれる
そこで体験する世界は涅槃というんです
いわゆる まあそれだけでいいんです
そこで ここまでは世界
これで今日は終わります
要件は 十分なかったですか
これはちょっと世間話です
世間 チッタ チェータシカ
それからルーパというつは世間なんです
それは我々生きてる全ての世界はそのつ
それ以上何もないはずなんです
で いわゆる認識機能があって
認識機能と同時に生まれるありとあらゆるもろもろの感情があって
それから認識機能働いている
物質的な世界がある それは主観的な
いわゆる自分の物質であろうか
客観的なその物質であろうか
それは関係ない 変わりはない
全部まとめて ですから世間体というんです
この世間体という場合は
ただの世間的な体という意味ではなくて
本当に世界の大転換ですね
その この存在の世界 存在の世界はこの三つだけですと
それを乗り越えたら もしその働き止まったら
で 涅槃という状態が生まれる
ですから それには出世間体というんです
出世間体 で 出世間体は認識できますか？できない
だからこれを乗り越えないと
だから涅槃はもう心のギリギリのところでしか体験できないものなんです
で 心がある人は まあいろんなものを見たり感じたり考えたりはするんです
それはものを いろんなものなんですね
その働きをどんどんどんどん見ていて見て
だからヴィパッサナーはそういうことをやってるんです
何かわざわざ見ようとするのではなくて
見えていると 聞いているんだと
波を聞いてるんじゃなくて
その機能を見ているんです
音があって 聞いていて
喜びが生まれたんだと
なるほど こういうところで喜びが生まれるとかね
そういうのをとことん体験して体現していて
この機能システムを見てるんですね
そこでそのシステムの苦しみであること
無常であること 苦であること
わかったらここで何かが変わるはずなんですね
その変わる瞬間で 現象でない世界というか
それは世界と言ったらおかしいんだけど
現象の超越という状態
その瞬間だけを体験する
ですから それは我々の勉強の認識の世界に入らない
涅槃というものは 勉強したってもわからない
わかるわけないんだから
理解もできない できるわけないんだから
理解も勉強も全ては世間体
世間の真実 大体アビダンマの基本的には
この四つの柱でアビダンマ成り立ってるんです
そこでずーっと苦労して
もう勉強するのはどっちかというと
このチッタ チェーサカ
ルーパという三つだけ
涅槃の勉強はしない 一応涅槃のちょっとした解釈
ちょっとちょっと入りますけど
まあそれは修行して もう心を乗り越えたところで体験するもので
それはどうしようもない
でも涅槃はやっぱり確実に得なくちゃいけないということは
ものすごい論理立ててはいるんです
時間が飛んじゃったんですけど
じゃあ一回目はそれぐらいで
どうもありがとうございました
帰りますね